this video is sponsored by Epic Games
yes from the craters of fort night comes
a new free-to-play RPG battle breakers
which is available to download in a link
below on PC iOS and Android battle
breakers is a hero collector turn-based
action RPG that was built as a passion
project by a small team at Epic and it
really feels heavily inspired from the
old nostalgic Saturday morning cartoons
you'd find in the 80s and 90s
that's not boomer that's not even close
to be my R you see why do I bother
assemble the perfect team from hundreds
of heroes you can collect in order to
save the kingdom and take back your
planet from the numerous monsters that
stand in your way you can choose your
hero team for a variety of different
reasons from the abundance of really
cool designs to their special attacks
team synergy or most importantly because
they wear right through numerous boss
battles to explore over a thousand
dungeons across volcanoes forests
glaciers and more and this game has also
cross-platform so you can tell your game
progress seamlessly across PC and mobile
if you'd like to give it a go click the
link below to download it on PC iOS or
Android again thank you to epic games
for sponsoring this video as we now get
to talk about some seasonal anime
alright guys I know I know it's already
halfway through for and my seasonal
video is late again you don't need to
tell me but to be fair I have some
really good reasons this time firstly
there's just a ridiculous number of new
shows this season for me to catch up
with and also if you didn't know I've
just moved to Japan so you know as you
can imagine with moving countries and
everything and there's just so many
things to take care of there have just
been eating my time but you can't even
begin to imagine
Sydnee clear out my schedule for the
next week
[Music]
does anyone wanna [ __ ] Leonardo da Vinci
fate is back at it doing fate things
finally getting to spend the billions of
dollars they've earned from the hopes
and dreams of their faithful playerbase
as they once again sink their entire
life savings for the worthwhile purchase
of a low low chance to obtain a JPEG
image of their favorite fictional anime
girl and honestly I don't know what more
Faygo fans could ask for this is looking
like it's gonna be a pretty decent
adaptation of one of the fan favorite
arcs and the animation is almost decent
enough to make you forget about the
countless quarts he rode away now that
you know you've been funding that shot
of not Rin sweeps in three ass as with
every addition to the fate franchise new
people are gonna ask if this is a good
place to start with fate and is just
like every other time the shortest
answer is going to be yes with an
asterisk the size of Jupiter next to it
but luckily I should have no problem
because I am already very familiar with
the source material wait a minute last
longer if you are still a nubian this
has gotten you curious about getting
into the game itself well I think this
unrelated review sums up the fates go
experience pretty well this is one of my
favourite games not recommended speaking
of gotcha games we have world of
warships
Lalli edition as your lane finally
spending their waifu bucks the smarts
way by sponsoring their own original
anime in a totally inaccurate
representation of the gameplay because
we got to see the Fox citizen episode
one man didn't actually have to spend
the next thousand years pharmacy for
Nerdist open as what is the most
successful breakout gadget games
obviously doing something right to be
able to fund this because there's such a
wide range of games now and people play
them for totally different reasons so
you know what I can only imagine what
the creators behind the game can say
about the secret to their success we
have so many degeneres here incredible
you know alright so getting to the meat
of the season chart there's a lot of
shows this season like a lot and there's
a lot of sequels this season like a lot
it looks like
a lot of the new high-profile sequels of
dominating the top of the chart but it
also looks like there's some fan
favorites coming back to but if you're
watching them before you probably know
if you're gonna be watching them now and
with so many new shows I don't really
want to waste your time going over the
same repetitive points you've heard
before about stuff you're probably tired
of hearing by now so anyway here's a
bunch new years ago I guess I just don't
have the strength to eat anything quite
yet mom told me I could be Eddie Sakai
protagonist so I became all of them can
we just appreciate how this first
episode went from a psyche I to hence I
Chi pretty damn quickly you know if that
didn't already exist Hey look as cute
goes Hui Sakai things Oh God
it's cute girls Dewey Sakai things have
we finally reached the endgame look I
get the ironic meta scenario of a girl
asking for average ability so she won't
be such an outcast only to be reborn as
the ope Sakai protagonist but have you
considered the real Opie ability she
received was the ability to make friends
[Laughter]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh crap out of nowhere we have lion
Kings the office giving us the anime
slice of wildlife we never asked for now
you may be looking at this and thinking
hey this looks and feels a lot like a
gret schoo and yeah maybe a Greco did
have the most charming donkey of all
time but there is one thing this show
has that a greco can only dream of
fortnight dances this video is sponsored
by epic black in the sakai corner we
have the world's biggest bookworm being
reincarnated into a world with hardly
any books and also from the crater of
kanasu becomes an esky where a pro
wrestler gets transported to a fantasy
world who immediately German suplex is a
princess I need to [ __ ] off and fulfill
his lifelong dream of opening a pet shop
by sniffing the busts of a bunch of
fancy animals and acting on is
definitely not fairy tendencies
remember when Issei Chi plots were just
a reskin version of soy bottom line
speaking of which wait a minute who are
you I'm you but what are you gonna
finish that sentence all I don't know
once I figure it out I'll get back to
you I'm only kidding guys this isn't
sword art online its sword art online
three houses I can't lie to you guys
this looks like it's gonna be one of the
most generic cliche trashy light novel
junk food shows of the season
I'm definitely watching this there's
always that one show every season I
somehow end up watching even though I
know it's detrimental to my health and
look I am a bit proud of myself guys
because I've finally upgraded from
generic Issei kind light novel trash too
generic magic high school light novel
trash on a side note even though I did
honestly mistake the scene for the new
season of Sao initially and compared the
character designs I don't think even
curator has reached this level of white
knighting in his life my D total ad
finally a man who knows how to properly
treat his lady I find it kinda ironic
that in a season where you have a new
anime from the author of kono Suba it
somehow isn't even the anime that felt
most similar to kono Suba if the title
the hero
is overpowered but overly cautious
doesn't already give away exactly when
the show is about I can say it honestly
feels like a spinoff a Sakai sitcom
starring blonde aqua and armorless
goblin slayer and it's honestly pretty
amusing because together they share some
pretty great comedic chemistry he
protects he attacks
she stays back but most importantly well
so I can't help but feel that the meta
nurse of Si Chi has been taken into
overdrive with truckin actually getting
name dropped in an earlier show our
wrestlers replacing a princess and now
cautious hero literally crafting a world
where goddesses are purposely summoning
a psycho protagonist from Japan because
of the popularity of ISA Kai is the new
ISA Kai trends just Issei Kai taking the
piss out of Si Kai if it is I feel
that's just awful absolutely awful I
mean come on
if ISA Chi starts taking a piss out of
itself how the hell am I gonna take the
piss out of it alright so tell me about
this idea yes alright so there's this
detective hmm and he has a gun for a
head that's it that's it that's
brilliant he has a gun for a head why is
no one ever thought this before he has a
gun for a head you keep saying you and
it just keeps getting better he has a
gun for a hat oh my god this is gonna be
the greatest show of all time you know
aside from the fight when I initially
scroll down his chart and mistook this
title as no guns no life didn't stick I
spin off I never knew I wanted there are
several ways that someone could have
described the show that would have been
able to easily sell it to me in an
elevator pitch an old-school hard-boiled
detective story in a cyberpunk setting
madhouse making a new gritty action show
with a stoic badass main character
budget Inferno cop but anything else I
could have been said was made irrelevant
when you have a protagonist with a gun
for a head and I wish it wasn't so
simple that I could have been sword as a
mere sight of a protagonist with a gun
for a head but there's a protagonist
with a gun for a head I don't think I
need to say anything else
[Music]
wait a minute isn't this music oh come
on
after cockier summer earlier this year
did a great job subverting the romance
anime cliche of two characters solving a
five dimensional Rubik's Cube in order
to figure out how to correctly say I
like you this season or uzuki's doing
something similar to the cliches of the
harem genre and honestly it was a really
pleasant surprise what initially looks
like a generic harem rom-com quickly
shifts when it's revealed that the
protagonist is actually the best friend
character of a generic harem rom-com
this is honestly a really nice twist in
what is usually an enjoyable but
predictable genre it remains to be seen
how the entire series will develop off
this one premise but right now it's even
introduced one of the nominees for new
anime villains of the Year bench sun-ho
Nakata kuru kuru kuru no car just cuz
conocchia Tim Ellison
[Music]
once again I want to give a shout out to
some Sports anime many people are gonna
sleep on merely for the fact that they
are sports anime
firstly I hear you know soda is giving
us a new basketball anime that is far
more reminiscent to the down-to-earth
classic slam dunk basketball story and
then we have another tennis anime
Nishino sorta giving us two very
promising news sports anime
these are two sports dramas that are
about a group of club members finding
their passion in the sport when they had
none and seems to focus more on how that
helps them cope with real-life issues
than the usual Sports anime formula of
building a team entering a season-long
tournament arc and winning something
before the samurais graduate for shine
Oh sorta especially as one of the few
anime original shows has been one of the
most impressive shows for me the season
and being criminally under watched just
remember that you should go into this
thinking this is more like a high school
drama with some tennis in it because
you'll suffer from a bit of emotional
whiplash if you come into with the same
mentality of you use your sports anime
like oh hey a tennis animate man's
utopia - is sure looking lit hahaha if
there was an award for surprise of the
season for me this was definitely it I
came into this completely blind and like
many people I took one look at it and
thought what the [ __ ] is this furry
convert to 9000 be stars takes place in
a world of anthropomorphic animals and
while that may sound like a cheap
gimmick the show uses this to craft a
believable world where the same kind of
social stigmas you see in our world
exist you have discrimination between
species class divides bullying it was a
very clever way to highlight similar
dynamics we see in our world and despite
us being a show about sentient animals
it has some of the most grounded
characters you can find all year which
all gives a nice backdrop for a
surprisingly dark and mature tale now to
address the elephant in the room yes
this is a 3d anime it comes from the
same studio that gave us this
Studio Orange has been one of the only
studio so far that can not only make 3d
work but make it work well they really
know how to play to the strengths of 3d
and it never feels like they are trying
to imitate anime but it's more like they
are doing it as an artistic choice this
really looks like it's going to be the
full package and a possible contender
for anime of the season so don't judge
this book by its cover because I can
definitely assure you this is not a show
for furries at all are you sure about
that
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
again thank you to Epic Games for
sponsoring me today if you'd like to try
out battle breakers you can click the
link in the description to download it
on PC or mobile and with that says thank
you very much to Axl Cloris Walter
supreme saying Nicholas Tatum Mike elfin
sisters one zero zero eight six and
everyone else on patreon 4 supports me
this month and helping me through my
move to Japan and yes if you did miss my
last video I have moved Japan and as you
can see I've been using it to her so so
my foot advantage on a serious note
though I am pretty excited for this move
I didn't really get to explain it in the
last video but a big reason why I wanted
to move to Japan aside from me being a
big [ __ ] weave is that I wanted to
explore new kinds of content which you
all hopefully see in the coming year
because next month I'm going to be busy
with anime in 2019 which again is
probably gonna take up my inside month
anyway those that's it for me I've been
gig up and I will see you all next time